not every battle is won on the
battleground dawes said i respect your
caution but holden hasn't asked you to
be vanguard hasn't even asked you to go
through the ring gate don't assume he's
going to demand heroism and sacrifice i
know his reputation but no one survives
the things he survived without having a
deep capacity for thoughtfulness and
foresight and more than that strategy
holden comes across feckless sometimes
truth but he's a thinker what he's doing
it's all from the head hey guys pete
here i've got a new expanse video today
that's sponsored by surfsharkvpn
today i'm talking death in the upcoming
final season of the expanse as we wait
for the season six trailer and for
leviathan falls to drop it's something
i've been thinking about for a couple of
reasons we had two major deaths in
season five that will change how things
play out in the books and we're heading
into what might be the last season that
ever gets made so it is a real question
i have and one i don't know the answer
to i'll be getting into all of that but
before i do a quick spoiler warning in
case you're not familiar with my videos
i do refer to the books which i've read
but i won't be giving away anything
specific not everyone in and around the
rossi is still alive going into the
final book but i won't be saying who how
or when they go out and with that out of
the way let's get started
last season we lost fred johnson which
was kind of a shock to book readers
because there he survived being shot in
the assault on tycho station when the
writers were asked about making the
change they said they did so because
they thought the story needed to have
costs they felt that they were making a
war story that didn't feel very heavy
because all the main characters seemed
untouchable nothing would ever happen to
them because they're the heroes this is
something that made sense to me the
first time i read them by the time i
made it to the fifth book the tension
was starting to fade when they got to
those big moments i wasn't really
worried about amos or naomi because no
one in the core group had died since
shed i still enjoyed the books it didn't
take me out of it but it did feel like
there were no real stakes for the crew
then at the end of season 5 we lost alex
that wasn't as much of a shocker
considering the crazy amount of
accusations that had been leveled
against him as he was out there in the
public promoting the series if you
followed that at all you knew the
corporations behind this stuff would be
cutting ties with him it was just a
matter if it happened in the fifth
season which had already finished
filming or in between seasons before the
final one started shooting fred's death
was planned from the beginning and alex
was an unfortunate thing that had to
happen and now there are stakes they've
been established but if that's their
intention does that mean that we should
expect that someone else will die in the
final season and what i think is
probably more interesting is anyone
protected for future seasons since right
now there aren't any confirmed plans as
far as the sixth book is concerned fred
was the big surprising death in that and
that is the one they're currently
adapting the situation where he dies
will likely still happen so maybe
someone else will take his place if
we're thinking that it's possible then
we have to zoom out and think about all
the candidates and some are more likely
than others regardless of how their
stories play out in the books
but before we get into that i need to
take a minute to talk about today's
sponsor surf shark with surfsharkvpn you
can change your device's location and
use the internet from different
countries around the globe surfsharkvpn
keeps your online identity safe by
encrypting all of the information sent
between your device and the internet and
that keeps your personal data protected
from big companies or cyber criminals i
use this all the time to unblock
geo-restricted content like trailers and
clips and you can also use it to access
different libraries and netflix
searching for better call saul in the us
only shows four seasons but when i
switch countries using the bpn i can
access all five seasons today if you use
my code you can get 83 off plus three
extra months free there's a 30 day money
back guarantee so you can try it out
with no risk surfshark even allows you
to use your account across unlimited
devices so make sure you follow the link
in the description below to sign up
the least likely of all the potential
candidates are the remaining crew of
holden naomi and amos of course it does
mean that it would be shocking if any of
them die but it does kind of wreck
things if they were thinking about
continuing after season six is complete
naomi and holden are individual
characters they have their own arcs they
both have great stories but they're also
necessary to each other especially if we
ever see an adaptation of those final
three stories i would be blown away if
either one of them die amos would make
for a memorable event that everyone
would be talking about afterward because
he is a fan favorite but he also seems
kind of indestructible and with all the
foreshadowing they did with hints about
naomi's kid and the rocks being thrown
at earth and how all of that stuff paid
off five seasons later the idea of amos
being the last man standing seems like
it's definitely happening he says it's
in his job description and i believe him
it's just kind of out there getting
kicked around and i do think there's
something to it i would be surprised if
something happens to him just like i was
with fred but with amos it would be far
more crushing from there everyone else
seems like fair game after all the rossi
might have a lot of extra people on
board in season 6. there has to be a new
pilot and it's kind of expected that
bull's going to step into that role amos
got clarissa on board and she's escaped
a life sentence so she'll be with them
at least for a while and also monica was
there at the end of season 5 and bobby
was there on luna with everyone else
which means it's not impossible that
she'll hitch a ride either it could be a
crowded place and some of those people
might end up there because they need
some casualties on board bull is kind of
brand new so they'd have to do some work
to make it matter if he got killed
monica's been around a little bit longer
but there's still a big difference in
how i would feel if she died compared to
clarissa or bobby they both do important
things later in this series all the
people i mentioned do but again that
might not matter if they're trying to
make this the most gripping season of tv
they can i'm not sure how invested in
clarissa show only people are she's a
pov character in the book so you get to
know her a lot better and it feels like
the show is still in the process of
building her up for me it would
definitely be sad to see her go but i've
read ahead for bobby they've gone out of
their way to keep her in the story ever
since they introduced her she kind of
comes and goes in the books but they put
her in the slow zone in the show and
they build a whole story from a novella
to keep her involved in season four if
she's around she's always in the mix
which means situations might present
themselves and there's a part of me that
thinks that she might be the most likely
candidate to not make it out alive away
from the rossi the only major characters
left are abasarala and drummer fans
would certainly hate to see avasarala
die but it's kind of hard to think of a
scenario that would put her in danger
and that would have a real effect on the
crew of the rasanante other than they
would just be mourning an ally if she
died it would be a big deal for bobby
but it still feels kind of far-fetched
there's also a little bit of that with
drummer although naomi certainly has a
connection with her but she still seems
to be the more likely of these two like
bobby she's probably going to be in the
middle of things if she's involved at
all and she should be on the run from
the free navy after the season 5 finale
fans love her so it would be an absolute
gut punch if something happened it would
be an amos level loss for some people
and you never know where they're gonna
take her so will they or won't they
that's the question it'll be interesting
to see if we lose another main character
and i think that's a good place to leave
things i'm curious to hear what you
think so let me know in the comments and
if you want to mention book spoilers
please mark those accordingly please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching i'll talk to
you soon